alright the White House is without one
of its high-profile and controversial
communication officials this morning
reality star turned White House aide
Omarosa Manigault Newman abruptly left
her post last night president Donald
Trump tweeted Thank You Omarosa for your
service I wish you continued success
major Garrett has been reporting her
story all right major what a story what
do we know about why she was dismissed
well this was put in place by his chief
of staff John Kelly John Kelly makes all
staffing decisions here at the White
House and though Omarosa had a big title
and a big paycheck associated with that
title her duties were hard to define
even for those who worked closely with
her and many sources have told us that
Omarosa sort of indulged in the
amenities and the conveniences of the
White House that aggravated the chief of
staff John Kelly as well as those who
worked around her and we are told Kelly
informed Omarosa earlier this week that
her time at the White House was over she
could stay until January 20th and would
be allowed to say that she resigned
that's the will officially she resigned
to pursue other opportunities but her
time here was done Omarosa tried to
renegotiate Kelly rejected that sources
tell us he then appealed to the
president's daughter Ivanka who took no
action one White House official denies
Ivanka was involved in any of this and
then Amoroso tried a different tact she
went into the residence that tripped
alarms there then Kelley ordered her
escorted off the property now the Secret
Service denies its agents were involved
in that maneuver but the service did
deactivate Omarosa s-- White House pass
all of this comes under the general
heading of chief of staff John Kelly
imposing discipline eliminating leakers
or eliminating those who create
unnecessary distractions within the West
Wing and creating a much more tightly
focused operation here on the
president's agenda and the president's
political future so now amorosa joins a
rather lengthy list of somewhat
controversial and highly public
officials now out of this White House
Steve banning the former chief
strategist Seban Chuck Sebastian Gorka
who worked in the National Security
Council and John who can forget
short-lived communications director
Anthony the mooch
it's been an amazing group you could fit
them all on a bus thanks so much major
Wow I mean it's just there's so many
details and you know I had forgot too
that there is that alarm if you try and
go up to the residence right that you
know that triggers a special alarm it
does sound like a different kind of
reality show not one that you normally
associate with the White House whatever
the circumstances it just it seems a
good look as the kids in today's and
John you know the chief of staff job
basically is to take the reality show
and replace it with reality which is the
tough difficult straightforward business
of running a White House and all of
these people who are a part of the
original group that came in are now
being escorted out never seen anything
like it